we're going to begin this hour with a
startling look at maternal health in
this country black women are about three
times more likely to die from a
pregnancy related cause in white women
the maternal mortality rate for black
women increased significantly from 2018
to 2020 the new documentary aftershock
follows the families of women who died
from preventable causes related to
pregnancy
we keep showing up we're not letting the
pain stop us we are holding people who
have the most power accountable for how
they use it
our maternal health community is really
pushing for change on capitol hill
trying to bring about
different legislation in order to make
sure that women have the care that
they're supposed to
i can't let amber be another statistic
i'm making people aware of what's going
on in these systems i planned on
spending a lifetime with amber i wanted
to give from my life
this way i'm still going to
oh the husband's stories are
heartbreaking tanya lewis lee is
aftershock's co-director and co-producer
dr neil shaw is chief medical officer of
maven clinic an assistant professor at
harvard medical school we welcome you
both good to have you here i want to set
the table guys with statistics from the
cdc so people have an understanding
about what we're going to talk about
black women three to four times more
likely to die than white women with the
same symptoms
over 60 percent of the deaths are
preventable and black women today are
more likely to die of childhood
complications than their parents which
means our daughters tanya have a better
chance of dying than we did
you know i i knew that this was a crisis
i'd sort of heard about it but when i
saw this documentary it made me so angry
and so sad i think aftershocks is a very
good title for it why is this happening
tonya
well it's it's happening because
unfortunately the health care system is
built on a system of racism and people
don't want to listen to black women when
they have have complications and
symptoms amber rose isaac shamani gibson
two women whose families we follow in
the film they went looking for help
and they were dismissed when they had
when they were expressing their symptoms
well they went to the hospital neil and
they were complaining about the symptoms
short shortness of breath i can't
breathe chest pains and time after time
in one case
the medical staff on three different
occasions says is she on drugs does she
do drugs why are black women not believe
do you think
tanya said that the health care system
is built on racism and one of the things
that i like to remind myself and remind
others of often is that
a bad system will beat a good person
every time
and you know bias is sort of built into
the way
doctors are trained uh were doctors are
trained to be biased what do you mean
they're not well you know there's a
really thin line between clinical
intuition which is celebrated which is
like looking at someone and knowing if
they're sick or not and what's
effectively racism
so you think it has to do with training
i think it 100 has to do with training
yeah now abortion isn't mentioned in
this film but the overturning of roe v
wade is the backdrop in which people are
watching this so when you think about
the connection between abortion access
safe births and also the overall
maternal mortality crisis
how do you see that all almost
laying together yeah i'm deeply
concerned i'm deeply concerned for black
women i'm deeply concerned about delay
of care when black women have
complications that they may have delayed
care i'm deeply concerned about the
criminalization of women
when there are miscarriages
i'm deeply concerned that that black
women will be criminalized i just think
that we are in a system in a situation
where the autonomy of women's bodies is
in in conversation and we are already in
a crisis around maternal health and the
dobbs decision just is going to
exacerbate it i believe there was a
study that just came out that 21 that
that maternal death is going to go up 21
given this decision 33 for black women
i don't think people realize this is a
crisis though guys there's a line in the
duck that really made the hair stand up
on my neck where it says black women
having a baby is like a black man in a
traffic stop what do you mean by that
well i think you got to pay attention
every step of the way
again when we as black people are in
certain systems whether it's the
criminal justice system or the health
care system as neil just talked about
there is a bias against brown and black
people and so you need to be paying
attention to who is dealing with you and
how they're perceiving you and making
sure that you advocate for yourself in
the best way possible in other words one
wrong move and it could cost you your
life absolutely you know dr shah one of
the things that i found fascinating in
the documentary is you talk about
cesarean sections and how before 1970
less than five percent of women who were
delivering had cesarean section
c-sections and it's risen by 30 in 2019
but the outcomes have remained the same
we're talking major surgery and yet
hospitals make more money if they
perform c-sections and spend less time
in the operating room with a patient
break that down for our audience that's
exactly right so since the 1970s
c-section rates have gone up by 500
percent it's designed to be a
life-saving surgery but the reason that
we're here is that maternal mortality is
going in the wrong direction it's going
up
uh and term infants are zero percent
better off uh on average over that time
period
and uh there's a lot of conventional
wisdom
about what's driving c-section rates but
they're only it's higher for black women
yeah it is even higher for black star
which i think is really revealing right
it's not necessarily that people are
demanding more c-sections it's that
people are investing less than
supporting people and labor which is why
the film depicts an alternate way to
support people but but yet you all say
that you want this film to be empowering
because i tell you i i choked up a
couple of times when you see the women
before they had their babies so full of
life and joy yes and what their husbands
are dealing with very excited to be
mothers excited yeah they were so ready
vlad
so i choked up but then it made me so
angry but you say tanya you want the
takeaway to be empowering i do i do
first of all i i think it is must-see
yes well first of all i think it's
really important that you feel for these
families and we needed to put a human
face
on on the women who are dying we read
the statistics but they're not numbers
they're people so you have to understand
who they are um but then on the other
hand you know we do show an amazing
birth in the film
by a woman who really decided i mean she
thought she was going to do the regular
thing and and then sort of made a
decision to see what other options are
out there for her so i would say i want
the film to be empowering because i want
women to come away and families to
understand there's choice in birthing
you can birth in many different ways you
don't necessarily have to do it at a
hospital
and that there are things that we all
can do to improve birthing outcomes and
it's really incumbent upon us to figure
out what that is well you gave us a lot
to think about one woman in the film
shimani makiba gibson who's no longer
with us we will not forget you i mean
it's very powerful and very well done
bravo to you both thank you thank you
the name of the documentary is called
aftershock it's streaming now on hulu so
you can actually see it today